welcome to this video playing pet speedy
maybe something else Kings Indian
Denmark Denmark flag Bishop e3 I
probably we go to their mission yep
after that okay I can prepare I can go
see 65 or and c6 be 50 or c5 it's both
them interesting now I get the bishops
at least something mmm should I go be 54
prepare that maybe prepare that okay if
it takes I have a choice i can take on
so on d3 and b5 I can play c4 just not
without its points or take just take
Bishop takes and Bishop a success also
not bad yeah hard to tell it's a
compensation in any case
yeah Queen before of course what's the
idea yeah I always liked it if they play
all all super committee moves instantly
always very frustrating if you don't win
after that but sometimes the instantly
plate moves are not so terrible yeah I
can take here I can take be too and all
looks good take here route takes 9292
Qin Jia hisk are they discovered
discovered move with the bishop but not
especially great one I can also take
here seem so good as well yeah I don't
know both seems good I can go Bishop c1
trapping my queen uh-huh like maybe I
could have taken you to this on the
other hand is just a blunder you five I
think it takes with the night I take you
through his check and see three hangs so
I just take it up
yeah I think you should take the night
at least again flick in gaol move like
that but it's not help much if always
just just lost so I'm two pawns upright
five against three and it's also the
better structure queen d 4 + 35 seems
seems easiest
just one more porn three pawns now and
I've got to look be true or look b3
coming rook b3 threatening look age
three yeah now is take my time very
signs I am again maybe I could have
played Bishop see one I really had side
too late Bishop see one I mean here here
i need to take on e to this is trapping
the Queen yeah this was lucky but ok he
played every move instantly without
thinking so it's it's only fitting that
he didn't consider this yeah here black
is already very comfortable I think it's
a matter of taste tell you how you play
it maybe you should take and I thought
that I have some good player but
something like this this may be stolen
sill ok rukia and ce4 was the idea but
dumb it's not clear or in this c4 you
might have this one yeah like has some
compensation but it's not super clear I
also could have taken here maybe this
would have been better even yeah maybe
maybe this is a better version like this
and tending Busia basics there's always
some compensation but how to tell
on which way exactly to play okay thanks
for watching